Gazi Hocam neredesiniz
Selamlar Neredesiniz hocam
benim kongredeyim hocam Hocam
neredesiniz birazdan geleceğim Şu anda
hocam ama hekimler bekletmez sizde
bekletmeyin bizi
sevgili Esra çok güzel sunum ve şu anda
Hani seni de görebiliyorum
bilmiyorum Sizler beni görebiliyor
musunuz
herkes duyuyor Hocam sizi süper Harika
Esra sunum için çok teşekkür ediyorum
Ben şu anda ben şu an Hacettepe
Üniversitesi
Meta Wars sınıfından size sesleniyorum
tabii böyle tıp fakültesini böyle bir
sınıfından Sayın rektörüm karşımda
dekanın da orada böyle bir sınıf
olduğundan haberi yok hocam Nereden
geldi bu sınıf diye O yüzden biraz
yukarıya yaptım sınıfı bulutların
üzerine taşıdım herhangi bir yer zaman
ve kişiden bağımsız dünyanın en büyük
sınıfı diyebilirim biz buna
şimdi bu sınıf içerisinde Şu an sizin
için bir hasta modelde hazırladık sahada
ve solda Bu hastanın görüntüleri ile
birlikte bir omurga tümörü hastası
şurada görmüş olduğunuz modeli üç
boyutlu olarak
öğrencilerin önüne getirin tümörü
değerlendirdikten sonra
net bir şekilde yapılacak olan ameliyat
ve ameliyat sonrası
neye benzeyeceği konusunda bir fikir
sahibi oluyoruz Aslında kısaca biz bu
görmüş olduğunuz mağara benzeri Yapı
içerisinde bir tıp fakültesini
sığdırabiliyor olacağız
şimdi Risale
-i
aleme doğru koşarak geliyorum
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
rektör hocam sürprizi beğendiniz
herhalde
teşekkür ediyorum Ben de
alternatif evrende yeni bir Tıp
Fakültesi kurulması noktasında bir fikir
ortaya atmış oldum Umarım Önümüzdeki
dönemlerde değerlendirilir şimdi
ben ismim Gazi Huri Hacettepe
Üniversitesi ortopedi ana bilim dalında
Öğretim üyesiyim
kültürlerin kesiştiği iki midenizin olsa
bile yetmediği yetmediği sıcağı ile
kavuran
kültürüyle savuran ama her daim keyifli
neşeli insanların
Kadim şehir Antakya'dan
gözlerime açtım
şimdi Hatay'ın bir sürü farklı
özellikleri var işte
mozaiğidi vesairesiydi Ama tabi biz
Akademi Sen olduğumuz için şimdi bu bir
yer gözlüklerini de önemli bir özelliği
saçları bozuyor Gözleri de
buğulandırıyor
ilk
felsefe bilim ve teknoloji okullarından
biri Antakya'da kurulmuş yılında Yani
şöyle söyleyebilirim ki hani Atina Okulu
meşhur bu portreyi biliyorsunuzdur 1500
yılda 1500 yıllarında Çağın ötesinde
düşünen her zaman kazanmıştır Çağın
ötesinde düşünen rafael'in çizmiş olduğu
bu portre Aslında günümüz teknolojisine
bize çok net anlatıyor Şimdi şöyle
sorayım ben size bu portrede şu anda
elinizdeki Akıllı telefonlardan Ben
iddia ediyorum ki 5 tane application
çıkarabilirim diye düşünüyorum şöyle
baktığım zaman
Şimdi şöyle beraber bunları bir
inceledik inceleyecek olursak Eğer
Platon bu dönemde yaşasaydı Twitter
kullanırdı
Bu hanımefendi kesinlikle bu pozunu
Instagram'a koyardı
Yani hayır diyen var mı
veya
bu arkadaş yandaki ne tinder üzerinden
yürürdü
veya buradaki arkadaş böyle eğilip
bükülmez WhatsApp'tan Çakar mesajı
geçerdi
şu rahat görünen arkadaş da
bu bütün bilgileri yan gelip YouTube'dan
izlerdi Aslında Rafael 1500'lü yıllarda
Çağın çok ötesinde bir tabloyla karşı
karşıya bıraktı bizi şimdi Çağ da
deyince
hepimizin
ilkokullarında duvarları süsleyen böyle
bir tablo vardır işte ilk ortaya Yakın
Çağ vesaire falan Şimdi burada Çağlar
arasındaki en büyük fark
dikkat edin dikkatinizi çekecek olursak
süre neden şunu soruyorum neden Çağlar
arasında süreler bu kadar farklı
ilerlemiştir ilk çağ 4.000 yıl sürmüş
İnsanlar bir türlü Çağ atlayamamış şimdi
milenyumla 2000'e giriyoruz Bence
Bilişim çağı 50 yıl sürecek 2050 yılında
bu uçağı bitecek yani ne oldu ki
insanlar Çağ atlamayı mı öğrendi Bu ip
atlamak gibi bir şey mi birinde 4.000
yıl birinde 50 yıl savaşlar mı bitti
açlık mı bitti Kıtlık mı bitti Çağdaş mı
olduk
Hayır bunların tek nedeni teknoloji
arkadaşlar Çağ atlatan şey dünyada
teknolojidir Bu da net görülmüş bakın 9
bin yıl hiçbir şey bulunamamış insanlar
karın tokluğuna çalıştığı için Çağ
atlayamamışız binli yıllardan sonra bin
1500-2000 derken teknolojinin
gelişmesiyle Artık çağ atlama değil Çağ
fırlatmaya girmişiz Yani atlamada değil
size soruyorum bundan sonraki bugüne
kadar olan oldu artık Bundan sonraki
hangi çağ bizi bekliyor
hangi çağ artık gözümüzü açacağız
düşündünüz mü
değişiklik olan Çağ bizi fırlatacak mı
yoksa gömecek mi şimdi her ne yaparsa
yapsın bundan sonraki bundan sonraki Çağ
şöyle söyleyeyim size
gölgeleri çalacak
işte çağı 10 g çağı Ama mutlaka
Gölgelerin Çağa geliyor Gölgelerin çağı
dediğimizde Mevlana'nın söylemindeki Ya
olduğun gibi görün ya göründüğü gibi ol
olmayacak artık
İnsanlar istediği gibi görünecek Çünkü
az önce benim ekranda yani Keşke Reha
Yavuzer hocam burada olsaydı onun
metaborste rica edecektim bana benzetsin
diye biraz Çünkü hiç benzememiş bana
avatarım hani Çünkü istediğimi
karşısına çıkabiliyordun veya bir cerrah
olarak
kilometrelerce uzakta bir hastanın
ameliyatına katkıda bulunabiliyor veya
çok Hani olur ya hiç tanımadığımız
biriyle evlenerek çok mutlu evlilikler
kurulabiliyor O yüzden Gölgeler çağı
dediğimiz Çağa
milattan önceki yıllara gittiğimiz zaman
platonun dediği gibi bundan sonra ki
hayatımızda Plato'nun mağarasındaki
gölgelerimiz bizi karşılayacak şimdi bir
anda sizi şöyle bir milattan önce
Savurdun bir milattan sonra savrulduk
ama aslında hep aynı şeyleri konuşuyoruz
o zaman da Gölgeler varmış
Ben bugün sizi biraz dünyanın en büyük
mağarasına gezintiye çıkaracağım
vietnam'daki mağara değil benim mağara
biraz daha keyifle eğlenceli bir mağara
şimdi yıl 93 Adana Fen Lisesi mezunuyum
Ben yatılı okudum böyle güzel bir okulda
okudum Hani o dönemler işte 12-13
yaşındayız ergenliğimizin böyle Tap
yaptığı sivilcelerimizin suratımızın
görünmediği yani sivilceye surat
koymuşlar gibi olduğumuz dönemlerde Biz
kendimizi geliştirmeye çalışıyoruz Çünkü
akıllı telefon yok teknoloji bir şey yok
biliyorsunuz ne yapıyoruz kitaplara
kendimizi veriyoruz Bir gün küçük saatte
bir kitapçıya gittikçe azıcık bir para
koymuşum Biz bir dükkana girdim
dedim ki Merhaba amca bana bir kitap
verir misin adamla sanki önceden
sözleşmişim gibi şu kitabı verdi
dedim ki amca dedim ben dedim tıpla
ilgili bir kitap istiyorum dedim hani
yüzüme mi Baktın Bana Böyle bir kitap
verdin diye şunu verdi
ya dedim ki
Hani Peki Tıp yoksa bari dedim Hani o
dönemler uzay vesaire falan çok şey
öyle bir kitap ver bari uzay astronomi
mi ver dedim bana bunu verdi
ya şimdi Dedim amca biz seninle
anlaşamayacağız dedim yani bana ne
istiyorsan onu ver dedim bana otobüs
biletini verdi okula geri gönderdi Ve
ben
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
ama o zaman hiç bilmiyorum dedi ki
cennet cehennem gezisi dedim böyle gezi
mi olur yani hangisi cehenneme gitmek
ister ki dedim ya Böyle bir gezi mi var
dedim neyse hemen Ben Cennete yazıldım
cennette yazıldım ama hepimizi aynı
otobüsle götürdüler
şimdi cennete cehennemin içinde gittim
50 derece
resmen böyle bir şeyle cehenneme doğru
cennete doğru gidiyoruz Neyse cennete
gittik
şöyle yukarıdan baya gidenler vardır
bayağı böyle basamaklı bir yer üste
böyle bir
Yapı var üstten bakıyorum ama devamlı
bir su sesi var Akarsu sesi şırıl şırıl
şırıl şırıl pır neyse işte ya sonra
bakıyorsun su yok yani derken böyle bir
yazı gördüm o yazıya baktım şöyle bir
şey şu Anladım tabi doğal olarak Ondan
sonra bilen birine sordum bu meğerse
mitolojik bir akarsunun
Hani temsili yazısıymış zamanında bir
vatandaşın biri o mitolojik akarsuda
ölmesin diye
Tanrıya dua ediyor
hani dedim ki ya olaya Bak ben de aynı
şeyi duydum ilahtan önce 500 yılındaki
adam da aynı şeyi duymuş ve o gerçekten
ürkütücü o bundan korkmuş Efendim merak
ettim yani olmayan bir şey bir şey bu
gölge de olabilir bizi hep aynı hislerle
ortaya çıkarmış durumda ki aklıma benim
platonun mağara alegorisini getirdi
bilmiyorum biliyorsunuzdur belki şöyle
hatırlatmak adına
platonun Devlet kitabının 7 kitabında
bir grup tutsak elleri kolları başları
zincirlenmiş bir şekilde ömür boyu
sadece tek bir duvara bakmak için
mahkum edilmişlerdir ve bu kişiler
hayatları boyunca bu mağaranın önünden
geçen kişilerin cisimlerin insanların
gölgeleri ile ve o Gölgelerin duvara
yansımasıyla
yapmış oldukları kendilerini bir yalan
bir hayat ortaya çıkarmışlardır
gerçekliği bu Gölgelerin oluşturduğunu
zanneden Bu insanlar bir de gördükleri
Gölgelere isim vermişlerdir o kadar
gerçekçi gölgelermiş ta ki Günlerden bir
gün bu tuzlardan biri
kurtulur ve kendini mağaranın dışına
atar
daha sonra
dışarıdaki gerçeğin içeriyle hiçbir
anlamı olmadığını görür kafası karışır
gider dokunur koklar kendini görür suya
Baktığı zaman ve sonra o kadar heyecanla
bir şekilde martısına geri dönerek bunu
arkadaşlarla anlatır içerideki
Gölgelerin yalan olduğunu ancak dışarıda
bunu çok farklı şeyler olduğunu gösterse
de arkadaşları tarafından bir güzel
harf fazladır işte sevgili arkadaşlar
bugün size Az önce VR oilus
gözlüklerinden biliyorsunuz o külüstür
modelini biliyorsunuz tek bir yerden
sadece ışık alan geri kalan üç tarafı
tamamen kapalı
sadece
karşımıza baktığımız şeyi görmemize izin
veren ve arkadan gelen ışığın kaynağını
hiçbir zaman göremeyeceğimiz o meşhur o
külüs gözlükleri Platon'un 21 yüzyıldaki
en büyük Mağarasının girişi Meta
words'ün girişi arkadaşlar
[Alkış]
bunu sadece ben söylemiyorum maksuken
Belki de öyle diyor gelin diyor Gelin
Tüccar adam gelin sadece Gelin alın hiç
satmak alın gelin Çünkü burada ölümsüz
Gölgeler sizi mutlu edecek diyor Aslında
bunu yıllar önce Üstad söylemişti bize
biz anlamadık anlamadık anlasaydık Belki
şu an Meta versü Biz bulabilirdik Çünkü
olay sadece mutlu olmaktaymış
meteorers
yılında yeni bir kavram değil aslında
niye
romanın da Türkçeye de parazit olarak
çevrilmiş romanda
Babil'in
gökkubbeye ulaşmak için Tanrıya ulaşmak
için kurmuş oldukları mitolojik kulenin
21 yüzyıldaki versiyonu olarak
anlatılıyor kitapta yıl 1992 yıl önce
kitabın konusu şu an birçok gencin ve
hepimizin Aslında duygularına da biraz
ifade ediyor
inanılmaz büyük bir Global dünyada
ekonomik kriz
işsizlik mutsuzluk ve hayatta kalmaya
çalışan bir pizza dağıtıcısı yani Çok
enteresan değil mi Son pandemi sonrası
92 yılında Pizza dağıtacağız şimdi
kuryeler diyebiliriz popüler olan
mesleklere dönmüş durumdayız ve onun bir
şekilde bilgisayar oyunu aracılığıyla
Herkesin mutlu olduğu ne istediğini
yapabildiği yiyebildiği gezebildiği
tanışabildiği Fakat bunların hepsinin
sadece gölgelerden oluştuğu yalan bir
dünyadaki yaşantısını anla diyor
anlatıyor kitap
Ben Meta virüsü şöyle hani benim için
neyin kısaltılmışı
Necdet hocam da kelime oyunlarını çok
sever ben de ondan Feyzi alıyorum
buradaki Meta mutlu eğlenceli toplum
algısı benim için Meta Verso anlamı bu
metaforce
eşittir Mutluluk bizim için de mutluluk
eşittir arsa arsa yani şu an bir
metaforce konuşması yapıp arsaya temas
etmezsem herhalde emlakçılar Birliği
beni indirir aşağıya Yalnız şöyle bir
şey dikkatimi çekti Bununla ilgili bir
şöyle bir ön araştırma yaptım arkadaşlar
meteorolojide Şu an sadece arsa alınıyor
satan yok Dikkat edin elinizde
patlayabilir sadece alım var
bu noktada bu noktada aynı zamanında
Hani Sülün Osman misali
olmayanları satmak gibi gelse de hani
arsa fiyatları çok arttı işte 50 bin
dolar 100 bin dolar vesaire diye ama
yine Sülün Osman
kampany sizin için güzel bir çözüm buldu
Üzülmeyin burada hani şu anki gece
konduların yerine şu bölgeden Meta kondu
veriliyor arkadaşlar o açıdan o açıdan
hani arsam yok diye üzülmeyin Burada da
yine sizin işinizi görebilir meteor
Sadece bunlar mı Bence bence bu şu ana
kadar konuştuklarım sadece Meta warsün
popüler kısmı hiçbir şey ifade etmiyor
arsa almak işte
ne bileyim birileriyle chatleşmek falan
gerekli olan bazı şey var önce siz
gerekiyorsunuz bir cevap yazılım içerik
ve daha sonra Mete başla girmeyi
biliyorsunuz bu noktada
Sonrasında da tabi dünyanın birçok
alanında olduğu gibi metal
alanı bizim için şu anda vazgeçilmez ki
2022 yılı tıpta meteoroloji yılı olarak
Çinliler tarafından herhalde Çin
takvimine göre tespit edildi ve
onaylandı Şimdi biz de artık Hekim
olarak Eğer öğrenci yetiştiriyorsa bunun
gerçeğini muhakkak aklımıza tutmamız
gerekiyor
bu nokta içerisinde şu unutmamak
gerekiyor şimdi Hani ben meteorge de bu
Yapılıyor şu yapılıyor demek istemiyorum
Benim Bizim daha doğrusu ekip olarak
Hacettepe Üniversitesi olarak geçtiğimiz
Mart ayında Avrupa Birliğine sabmide
ettiğimiz yani yüklediğimiz brezilya'dan
Bruno combato'nun sevdiği bir ortopedi
arkadaş ki tıptaki ortopedinin
metabolsun hep birlikte yapmış olduğumuz
orta virüs Müzesi
ortopedi gezegen projesi bütün alanlara
evrilebilir Az önce ben O projenin
içindeydim şimdi çıktım buraya geldim
ama proje arkamda dönüyor
ortak projelerin değerlendirmeleri de
var anlayacağınız birçok şey var Aslında
sadece bu değil Bakın bu gerçek bir
hasta bruno'dan aldım Bruno teşekkür sağ
olsun geçtiğimiz hafta bana bunları da
gönderdi normal diz muayenesi sırasında
Düşünsenize dokunduğunuz yerin MR'ı
karşınızda sağ anatomisi sol tarafınızda
büyük bir şey doğru ilerliyoruz Eğer
bunlarla Sadece bunlar değil ama hayat
sırasında aklınıza takılan bir nokta
varsa da bakın bir anda New York'ta ki
arizona'daki Güney Afrika'daki Kore'deki
arkadaşınıza danışa biliyorsunuz Hatta
ve hatta başka bir arkadaşınızın size
modeli de yine hastayı implant
edebiliyorsunuz o kadar enteresan ki
sadece Meta Wars Eğer Viar teknolojisi
anlamında olmadı anlamında değil Ama
eğer ve bir yer meteorsün olmazsa olmazı
önce Dünyada sadece 80 ortopedik
cerrahının aktif üye olarak kabul
edildiği Amerika kemik eklem cerrahisi
derneğinde tartışıldı
üyesi olmaktan çok keyif aldığım
gurur da duyduğum çok değerli hocalarla
birlikte çok muhteşem bir kongre
geçirdik Venedik'te 2 hafta önce neden
muhteşem diyorum
orada
benim astronot bir arkadaşım var salonda
var mı astronot arkadaşı olan benim var
bu astronot arkadaşımız aynı zamanda
ortopedist Hani uzaya ilk gönderilecek
Türk'ten bahsediliyor ya hani
ortopedistler gidebiliyor mu yani onu
demek istedim Bu arada hani orada
yabancılık da çekmeyi
eşim şöyle ters ters baktı bana
sevindi herhalde şimdi Bobi
bize
robotik cerrahiden bahsetti ama hani
standart olarak işte kıtalar arası
robotik cerrahiden değil gezegenler
arası robotik cerrahiden bahsetti şu
anki onun hayali
daha da üzerine çalıştıkları şey
robotların dünyadan kontrol edilerek
Mars'taki
hastaları ve astronotları nasıl tedavi
edilir konuşması yaptı ki inanılmaz
etkilendim onu da ayrıca paylaşmak
istedim Ama tabi robotlar bizim Hani
hayatımıza gelecek mi
şimdi Bununla ilgili bu konuşmadan ve
bunları gösterdikten sonra ya meslek
elden gitti Tıp bitiyor artık robotlar
bizim burada muayene edecek gibi
söylemler yani hani açıkçası silikon
vadinin kontrolüne giriyoruz noktasında
Bence Çok üzülmeyin Çok üzülmeyin çünkü
robotlarda olmayan 4 şey var Bunlardan
bir tanesi
robotlarda vicdan yok
yani robotların programlanabilir ve
programlanamayan iki farklı komponenti
var hekimin Siz bir hekimi %100
programlayamazsınız
Evet çok güzel dikiş attırırsınız kesin
yaptırırsınız ama hekimin
programlanmayan kısmını ki hekimi Hekim
yapan kısmını robota yükleyemezsiniz
bunların başında Vicdan gelir eşinden
şiddet görmüş bir kadının kolu kırıldığı
zaman
bir robot onun kemiğini tedavi eder ama
kalbini edemez veya çocuk yaşta
çalıştırılmış olan işçilerin ellerinde
bir kesesi varsa o keseyi Diker ama
hiçbir zaman o çocuğa sahip çıkamaz Hele
ki Hele ki
Ligi 13 bitirmiş Galatasaray'ın yerine
hangi robot kendini koyabilir ki yani
empati yapabilir ki çok zor bence
Galatasaraylı birinin teşekkür ediyorum
Fenerbahçe
Sadece bu mu arkadaşlar robotlar eşittir
adil değildir
hekimliğin önemli bir komponent'i de
Adil olmasıdır robotlar dışarıdan
devamlı her ne kadar meşenin örnek varsa
şimdi burada mühendis arkadaşlar kızacak
Hocam işte sadece yükledikleriniz değil
artık robotlar meşeli ile kendini
geliştiriyor geliştirse de onun 0
noktası insanlar tarafından konulduğu
için robotlar hiçbir zaman Özgür
düşünemeyeceklerdir inisiyatif
kullanamayacaklardır ben Robin robotun
önüne böyle bir görüntü koysam ve bana
ayırıcı tanıların ne diye sorsam işte
geniz eti diyecektir iltihaplı romatizma
diyecektir bağırsak polibi diyecektir
mide kanseri diyecektir Ama hiçbir robot
buna dolmalık biberin içi demeyecektir
şimdi o yüzden korkmayın arkadaşlar
yerimize robotların girmesi çok kolay
değil ki önemli özelliği
hiçbir robot aynaya bakamaz aynaya
bakmayan da eksiğini göremez İlla
eksiğini bir sana oğlunun düzeltmesi
gereken bağımlı makineler olacaktır
robotlar şimdi diyeceğiz ki hocam bu 4
güzelliği bıraktık robot olalım Peki
Bence bunların dışında Türkiye'de de
robot Doktor olmak ayrı bir meziyet
gerekti ayrı bir zorluğu vardır robot
doktorluğu önce biz isim takarız adı
doktor olur robot doktorun adı doktor
şimdi ilk gün buna bir
polikliniğe verdiğiniz zaman ve icap
Nöbet tuttuğu zaman Bence algoritması
problem yaşıyor Algoritma sorunu yaşar
Ne bileyim patates yedikten sonra kalbi
kaşınan bir hastayı dermatolojiye mi
Gönderecek Cinler kovalayınca ayağı
burkulan bir hastayı Ortopediye mi
Gönderecek psikiyatriye mi Gönderecek
sırtı eli sırtına ulaşmıyor ne krem
sürmeyi robot mu yapacak bunların
hepsini biz yapıyoruz Arkadaşlar biz
hekimler bunların hepsini yapıyoruz Sen
sadece reçete yazmıyoruz Bunların hepsi
cevap veriyoruz ki en önemli yaptığımız
şey ne biliyor musun WhatsApp'a cevap
veriyoruz Biz gecenin bir yarısı böyle
bir fotoğraf açık hangi robot cevap
verebilir ki
veya gecenin gecenin gecenin 11
buçuğunda 11 buçuğunda aynı gelen mesaj
Sayın Gazi uzatma ücreti ne kadar diye
bir soruya gecenin 12'sinde
nasıl cevap verebilir ki bir robot O
yüzden Arkadaşlar bence çok da fazla
robotları ciddiye alalım ama unutmayın
herkes pilav yapar ama hiç kimse
annenizin yaptığı pilavın Tadını
tutturamaz robotlarda ancak böyle
doktorluk yaparız
işte önemli bir sorun hasta yakın
olduğunuz
u hasta yakınsın Şimdi onların da
gözleri var bir hasta yakın Asli görevi
doktorla iletişim kurmaktır doktora ilk
iletişim kuracağınız zaman soracağınız
soru ne hocam memleket diyecek ki made
çayına dizaynın
o hareketleri yapmak zorunda veya
Düşünsenize Şimdi yüzde doksanlara
çıkmış hekime şiddetin robotlara yapman
için hacker olman lazım bilgisayar
işletmecisi olmayan programcı olman
lazım yani Akıllı olman lazım akıllı
insan zaten hekime şiddet yapmazsın
en önemlisi de en önemlisi de bunların
hepsini yaptınız kime şikayet
edeceksiniz robotu
hurdacılar Çarşısı başkanının kime
şikayet edeceksiniz Ne yapacaksınız yani
o yüzden bence
robot Türkiye'de çalışacaksa beyninin
içinde bazı ufak tefek şeyler olsa
yeterli olur diye düşünüyorum şöyle
baktığınız zaman bitiriyorum ufak
noktacıklar ve büyük alanlar vardır
Beynimiz bir harita gibidir Hani derler
ya küçük yerleri her zaman Önemsiz
şeyleri koyarsınız
bizim Beynimiz buna benziyor hekimler
olarak bilimsel araştırma cisimciği
maddi tatmin noktacıkları sosyal
iletişim hobi çekirdeği gibi biraz daha
büyük alanı robotun rapor yazmamak için
bahane merkezini koymanız gerekiyor
veya Ya sabır Merkezi robotu yüklemeniz
lazım Gelecek kaygısı aile Özlem
alanları garip reçeteleri yazmamak
üzerine uygulamalar ve en önemlisi
muhakkak ve muhakkak şiddetle direnme
alanlarında robada yüklerseniz bizim
roktorumuzu beyin göçüyle Mars'a
göndermeyiz
çok dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür
ediyorum
seçimi size bırakıyorum
mağaranın içinde mi kalacağız ve bize
gösterilmek istenen şeyleri gösterip
Mesleğimizi icra ediyor yoksa insani
özelliklerimizi koruyarak hayatımızı
tekrardan insani olarak sürdüreceğiz mi
seçim sizin çok teşekkür ediyorum